I just absolutely love doing these shows
at comic-con and I'm gonna say right now
so far this year's comic-con has been
totally and completely okay
really good yeah it's it's I can't
believe it sighs that Kemp said right
from Game of Thrones and Isaac I'm sorry
as if you needed to me to tell you that
what's the problem I think did I say
something wrong I mean just don't do
that don't just stare at me like bran
the broken I think you mean behind the
king and did you really say this is
comic-con is just okay not unbelievable
or earth-shattering or an experience so
singularly entertaining you will choose
to spend the remainder of your life
plunged into complete darkness lest you
accidentally set your eyes upon another
comic-con that compares unfavorably to
this year's preceding
sorry I just don't see what the big deal
is worth saying Comic Cons okay oh it is
a very big deal and I assure you this
wonderful audience did not come all the
way to San Diego well where they'll have
to stand in line for six hours and
that's just the line for the donuts for
an experience that's merely okay in that
right guy dressed as a familiar but
legally clearable superhero
I I just came here for the air
conditioning so and what about you young
lady who probably wishes she hadn't
cosplayed as Diaby from Harry Potter in
90-degree heat okay I yes I get it Isaac
you made your point
not yet I haven't according to these
remaining cue cards would you settle for
an okay x-men film well I I think we all
did
bad example how about this would you
hire an okay plastic surgeon to have
your lips professionally thinned like
that I think these are my real lips they
were not thinned and no I wouldn't and I
guess you'd be fine subscribing to an OK
wireless network what did you just say
to me was it the thing about your lips
no no it wasn't don't ever ever accuse
me of settling for an okay wireless
network I'd rather use a scented candle
that smells like the inside of an
unwashed riddler costume then use a
wireless network that's just okay I need
to know I'm using America's best
wireless network and that's exactly why
I use a titi
hey that could be a great ad for a CNC
Isaac I think it was
[Applause]